there were ten sharks at the reef and we
see there's one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten sharks just like
they told us
two sharks
swam away i was gonna say ran away they
swam away
how many sharks are left so let's think
about it
there were ten sharks at the reef and
two of them
two of them swam away so how many sharks
are left how many sharks are left well
what's 10 minus 2 going to be equal to
well we could look up here if we had 10
pictures of sharks and we were to take
away
we were to take away
1 and then 2 how many are going to be
left
well we see we have one two three
four five six
seven
and eight
so ten
minus two ten taking away two sharks the
two sharks that swam away
is going to be equal to
eight